yummy to do what gimme sick word can you
tell me how I'm gonna fit there how you
want me to fit there daddy
hey say hello to everybody Billy
say Billy I Dylan James for David will
one day be a great leader five high five
high five Billy tickle he won't do it
it was pretty serious focus right now
building the word unity is a very very
powerful word unity I think there's
three countries out there that started
with the word United whether it's United
Arab Emirates or United Kingdom or
United States of America there's some
very powerful about the word unity
United when a country is united you
advance when a family when these two
boys are united it's peaceful when
they're not united this house feels like
a hurricane hit us when they're not
united Sunday early in the morning and
if you have kids you know kids are 24/7
they're not 9:00 to 5:00 you don't have
shifts with kids
from the moment they wake up they wants
you to you know do anything and
everything for them they're constantly
asking for things they constantly need
to be watched but this morning I woke up
and last time I went to sleep late my
wife first time in nine years she
surprised me baby did good and when we
went to dinner
nothing big on my birthday's coming up
on the 18th so we went to dinner October
18th
we went to dinner and dinner she gave me
a card and there was concert tickets to
Marc Anthony which it doesn't take a lot
to please me you don't need to buy me
clothes cuz only I know what type of
clothes I like you don't need to buy me
shoes because only I know what kind of
shoes I like I like surprises I like
things that matter artwork things that
have a meaning behind them good books
old vintage books anyways so we slept
very late and kids woke us up this
morning and I'm up out here they want to
jump run to all this stuff and I was
thinking about values and principles I
think so many times we'll make a list of
goals you know we want a big house right
now we're looking at a house to buy
that's it's a big house this is a pretty
big house already it's nearly ten
thousand square feet but we think about
a house with cars some of us not all of
us but you know the finer things of life
the nicer restaurants to go to
maybe faint maybe prestige maybe respect
maybe recognition maybe validation all
those things matter and there's nothing
wrong with any of those things mattering
to you sometimes some people want to
knock part of it that matters to you
while the part of it that doesn't matter
to them they feel they're superior to
you
don't let anybody fool you something
drives you you go get it it's your
business not anybody
but but I will tell you one of the
reasons why very few dreams and goals
become a reality is because we live life
so fast that we don't take a moment to
find out what values and principles we
want to live by I think it was seven
years ago where I was in Hawaii now woke
up told my wife I said you scrub a paper
and pen and I just started making a list
of values and principles that I live by
and I think we came out with
40-something names and at 40 something
lists and then from there the 40
something went to the top five and then
the top three and then you know these
guys showed up out of nowhere
but values and principles are very
critical because values and principles
if you stick to them they will be as
loyal to you increase the faith your
spirit has and the words that come out
of your mouth and the more you
compromise your values and principle the
more you're disrupting the momentum that
you have in your business which prevents
you from having an explosion see it all
fits together values and principles
being compromised is what disrupts every
other aspect of your life and you know
what is it travel all the money in the
world you gotta have all the money in
the world and enjoy it but the people
that matter the most you so I started a
video with the word unity because unity
is a very very strong word
United a very very strong word my
suggestion to you would be to make a
list of your values and principles and
ask yourself which ones you're gonna
live by and do whatever you can to not
compromise them and not let others
compromise it unless if they need
improvements and adjustments but not
something that if it needs to be
completely compromised you'll have a lot
of battles internal battles and you
don't want that so for me this goes back
in the military when in September of
1997 I started praying and asking for
four things courage wisdom tolerance
understanding courage wisdom tolerance
understanding I need courage to not be
afraid for lead other people and
challenge them and put myself in
positions that I may have fear but have
courage wisdom to help make the right
choices and tolerance to know that I'm
dealing with the product which is human
beings that change regularly more than
the weather does and then
understanding because everyone's
different and if you can't sit there and
try to understand people for the
position they're in in the situation
they're in and you're putting everybody
in the same box and one it's unfair and
two you can't get the most out of people
if you think everybody is the same
everybody takes in a different way
everybody who's driven by different
things typically we have similarities we
want to be somebody one there's some
special we driven by different things so
understanding helps you in dealing with
other people my kids are very different
tako demands respect I mean he is like
expecting it from you
from the day that kid was born Dylan's a
charmer
you know easygoing
playful always smiles my reviews with
him with this teacher is different than
my reviews with Chico's teacher but I
have to do my best to try to understand
both of them I think God throws me a
curveball and gives me a daughter named
sent a role and she's gonna be
completely different these guys so
courage wasn't onerous understanding
it's a rant
today's a rant it's a Sunday this is not
a anything about your business but for
the sake of Sunday I hope this message
gives you some kind of guidance in any
part of your life not related to
business any other thing that's can help
you get a bit more clarity I'm just
telling you what I've done God knows
I've made a lot of mistakes but these
thoughts have helped me to minimize my
own internal battles that have had all
my life
okay make it a good to everybody take
care bye-bye